first I'd like to thank the organizers
for inviting me here it's exciting to be
on campus of Columbia University I've
never been here before but a part of it
many many times because it was my wife's
dream to go to grad school here it did
not work out but you should heard how
what a wonderful place this is let me
start in prehistory transmission of
scientific knowledge are you more
generally the knowledge of how the world
works has always been done orally from
mother to child or from you know to the
neighbors or members of the tribe don't
ease the dog when he's eating those
kinds of things are have been
transmitted orally have been transmitted
orally and and are still transmitted
orally that's why this building has this
very room for oral transmission of
scientific information or knowledge
information between members of the tribe
now when I say members of the tribe we
can go back to prehistory again a tribe
that has the knowledge of how to start a
fire instead of just steal one or how to
make a superior bow and arrows is going
to have a serious advantage over the
other tribes and that advantage can be
measured in lives and deaths so
knowledge has power in real world power
so secretiveness about knowledge is
something that we've had with us for
millennia because whoever possesses
useful knowledge has advantage over the
competitors
so it is not surprising that a more
narrow scientific tribe was quite
secretive for a long time for a long
time going this guy and he is huge but
weak is making smaller is Newton he and
many of the great scientist of the old
old ages they did not publish in
scientific journals they did not have
say anything out in public because for
them knowledge was power they are either
personally rich or they had rich
sponsors okay they could afford to spend
10 20 years building a humongous
theoretical construct which then gets
published in a book and at time
publishing books was not easy or cheap
either you had to be well-connected or
rich or have a rich sponsor in order to
publish a book once you publish a book
like Principia well that's a it's a
monument to your intellect and that's
how you become famous and be rich from
the sales of the books because they are
expensive so at a time when Newton and
some you know and the others were
publishing and that is 17th century CE
1686 Principia was published as a book
and Newton didn't like the idea of
having journals this is also 17th
century the 17th century is pretty much
the beginning of the journals it was a
radically a radical idea that was open
access of the 17th century people like
newton-- did not like the idea at all
they're fighting it tooth and nail they
wanted to keep their secrets why because
knowledge is power and there are very
very privileged members of the society
not everybody could afford to be a
scientist it was a very small tribe
heading journals out meant that a lot
more people could do and publish science
and get maybe livelihood from it maybe
fame from it but the mode of doing
science then became different because
you could do a couple of experiments and
publish immediately you don't have to
construct an enormous theoretical
construct that fits in a book and wait
10 or 20 years until that's done you can
kind of go along as your research is
progressing you can report on that as it
goes one experiment at a time three
experiments at a time and and tell the
world about what you're doing the whole
movement of starting journals and it's
similar to what's happening today was
really a relatively small number of
people having a vision and then pushing
for it really really really hard because
they well they had to deal with mutant
who didn't like it and they had to deal
with some very very powerful forces
against journals against scientific
journals as a concept this is not how
science is done science has to be
secretive because science is power so
the journals did prevail after a while
and it became a norm it changed the
world science was done instead of
working for 20 years in publishing a
book publishing a book these days
doesn't really mean much it's kind of a
side project for you oh you published a
book cool cute your scientific career is
measured in your publications in a
journal right now we are in the midst of
let's say a second transition in the
openness while the initial journals 17th
and 18th century democratize science as
much as they could at that time what
they could do is print the head printing
presses and that enabled a much larger
number of scientists
to become known prominent published to
get jobs to get promotions within their
institutions it wasn't a really global
and really democratic but much better
than what it came before now we have
we've had the world wide web for 20
years now or something like that and the
web is really changing everything we do
it's really globalizing information and
this is having some big effects on the
way science is communicated and this I
think is going to change the way science
is done just like the first let's a
revolution in scientific communication
has moved from making overarching
enormous theories that take 20 years to
build into smaller snippets I think this
under you know that the transition that
we're going through is also going to
change the way we are doing science not
just publishing it so what I mean by
that this is a slide picture that i
shamelessly stole from Michael Nielsen
was up at perimeter institute in in
Canada who wrote a absolutely wonderful
essay about he's writing a book about
future of science and a lot of ideas I
have I stole from Michael or sometimes
we had the same idea at the same time
like okay great minds think alike what
every change every revolution in
technology that affects the way science
is communicating does is expands the
proportion of the useful knowledge that
becomes shareable shareable means i can
tell you and you can tell me and or we
can all read it more people can read it
more people can find it which is
an important thing to think about that
the first journal is what I did is they
could publish scientific papers today
with a web we can do more than that
there's not just scientific papers there
are many other ways of sharing
scientific ideas scientific data and
information with others so there are
scientific papers which are kind of a
final version of a story containing
several experiments the idea of the
conclusions coming out of it we now have
preprints it's pretty easy and cheap to
put ideas up there were before they're
completely digested and done and people
then from around the world can come look
at your stuff and comment on it and say
hey maybe you should try this I'll try
that I think that you're wrong about
this detail so it's kind of a work in
progress and once it's done then you can
submit it to a journal and becomes a
paper data data usually set in hand
wrong notebooks and I'm not going to
steal the thunder of the people after me
because they're going to focus much more
on that the data the notebooks all of
those things can be easy now placed on
the web and thus shared freely so if I
publish a paper which contains a large
data set somebody else can come in and
look at the data and crunch it in a
different way pass it through a
different piece of software see what it
comes out adds another idea meshed with
something else or use the same let's say
method that you use on a different data
set and see how it compares this allows
many more people to use the same amount
of the same data set in a useful way
which speeds up the progress of
scientific knowledge video is another
thing you can't put video on paper you
can put video online
many of you here are working scientists
or used to be and you try to do
something in your lab and you are
reading materials and methods section of
the paper and you try to replicate
that's what materials and methods
section is for to allow people to
replicate did you actually manage to
replicate no there's always missing
information and it's always not oh not
always easy to understand what is well
really done there is a lot of tacit
knowledge that is passed from adviser to
student over generations over and over
and over again never shows up in papers
how can you learn let's say a technique
that you want to use in your laboratory
video provides a great way of doing it
because video is going to show you
things that the person doing it is just
never going to think about you know of
course everybody knows this is how it's
done this is how you decant but what if
somebody is a novice and doesn't know
how to decant you see that on the video
it's not written material as the methods
but you can see you can see how it's
done so a lot more useful knowledge can
pass through uses of new technologies
like video audio or data they can be
automatically put in your software
reanalyzed in different ways for all of
this to happen do they have to be free
one thing about the journals is that
they are printed paper ink print presses
trucks and drivers who drive them it's
very very expensive stuff putting stuff
online is very very cheap you need to
buy a computer okay thousand dollars or
you can go to the library into it so
it's really really much much cheaper to
put stuff online and no need to charge
for it anymore and if you don't charge
for it anymore then everybody can access
it now that is really democratizing
because it's not just that you know
mutant and Galton and those people can
exchange information with each other or
people at big universities like Columbia
can concede because their library with
many many you know thousands and
thousands of dollars into journals but a
scientist in a in a budding scientific
community in Morocco can also read the
same thing use the same data see the
same video and promote him or herself
because he's smart has good ideas maybe
doesn't have the infrastructure at home
to utilize to actually do what needs to
be done but it can get in touch with
others who can and collaborate so it's
really democratizing in the sense that
it's globalizing you don't have to be at
Columbia or Harvard or MIT or anywhere
else in order to become a good scientist
and and enter the world of elite science
you can be wherever you want you can be
at a small community college you can be
in high school I mean a high school
teacher or something like that you can
be in a developing country and still if
you have smart have an interest you can
contact others you can connect with
others you can reanalyze others people's
data you can come up with great ideas
and start collaborations and test those
ideas even if your country or your
school doesn't have the money to pay for
journals or the infrastructure for you
to have all the laboratory equipment
that you need so I'm putting science
Commons out there because they are
really promoting the the ways of sharing
the information coming up with licenses
how to share information free with
everybody who is interested in it
regardless of their socio-economic
position their employment or the country
of origin
opening research so two people after me
they're going to talk about their
ongoing efforts but it's pretty
important to be able to to see what's
already been published and that's where
we come to open access open access
movement is a movement to try to to make
all the published research which means
the finalized papers made free available
online and here we have some terms we'd
have to make lien free access means you
don't have to pay when you go to the
website it doesn't ask you for six
dollars to see a paper which is really
really important especially if you're in
a country where sixty dollars is a
annual income so the other thing is open
access true open access allows you know
just to access it for free but also to
do stuff with it you can translate it
you can reanalyze the data you can copy
and paste and write a blog post about it
without having to pay anybody for
copyright all you need to do is to say
this is where I got the data from from
this paper you link back to it so
there's a difference between free access
and open access another two terms that
the differ are green open access and
gold open access green open access is
what libraries do and that means when a
paper is published the copy of it gets
posted on a library repository or
institutional repository which has been
made free for everybody to access gold
open access is actually an open access
journal you submit the manuscript in
open access journal at the moment it's
published it's free and open for
everybody to see download mashup
translate redo whatever they want to do
with it those two are often presented as
in clash with each other but I don't
think so i think they actually work
together well because they're pros and
cons to both one of the for me at least
the big pros of green open access is dig
and go back into the past if you publish
a brand new paper in PLoS Biology for
instance it's brand new research but
often we need to dig back into the past
into the papers that have been published
twenty fifty hundred years ago
repositories are slowly going back into
the past and capturing that historical
knowledge which otherwise will be
forgotten and it's important important
knowledge base that that we have to work
on and work with so that's that's for me
that the biggest importance of the green
the gold open access or open access
journals thing is immediacy there's no
need to wait six or twelve months to get
the the the the paper published and it's
immediately out there now I work for
plaza have to do a little PR applause
this is one of the papers in plus one
plus one is an experimental journal in
the sense that it doesn't have a theme
or topic topic it covers all signs we
get a lot of interdisciplinary
manuscripts which really don't fit
anywhere else another thing is that it
really is trying to connect the
scientific paper this kind of old style
way of communicating with the rest of
the online ecosystem so see we can have
notes and comments that people post on
there and
user ratings where people rate but also
trackbacks so when somebody writes a
blog post it's directly connecting to
this paper and the paper is connecting
back where we go to the whole thing of
you know the blogosphere blogs wiki's
everything else is connected the
scientific paper is not going to be an
isolated unit anymore it's going to be
interconnected with all sorts of other
parts of of that ecosystem and I think
to finish that in the future a
scientific paper instead of being a
discrete thing which has a date of
publication and a place of publication
is going to be a much more dynamic
process thing where a number of
different people are going to do
different parts of the study and posting
them online in real time and then only
in the end you put all those pieces
together and call them a paper this is a
study so you don't have to wait until
everything is done then you submit and
then suddenly secrecy is over you're
open I think it'll go dynamically over
time we're not there yet but the next
two people are going to tell you about
the efforts to make that future come
true thank you thank you borrow those
are actually a great introduction I
should always have you before my talks
because you really cover the whole gamut
of where we are right now so I'm going
to be able to go through this a little
bit more quickly I will be talking to
you about one of the specific
applications that boar was alluding to
which is open notebook science so
there's actually a definition now on
Wikipedia and if you're interested in
you know links articles and all that
kind of thing you can go but the idea is
very simple is that if you're doing a
research as an experimentalist in the
lab you keep a lab notebook if you make
that lab notebook completely public and
as close to real time as you can that's
open notebook science so what that means
is that you know you don't decide I'm
going to share this experiment but not
this one and the reason for that is we
really want to see how science happens
and we want to see the failures as well
as the successes we want to see the
errors get corrected we want to see how
the whole thing happens so that's
basically what i mean by open notebook
science now again going back to some of
the concepts of war was mentioning we
want to be able to track the provenance
of the information as it goes through
and one of the things we forget when we
read a journal article or a book is we
start to believe what it actually says
are facts alright but any measurements
right there's actually no such thing as
a fact every measurement is embedded
within assumptions and if you don't know
what those assumptions are then you're
missing out on information and you don't
know what how much value to place only
on that piece of information so though
with open note nub of science we're
maintaining the integrity of the data
provenance by making those assumptions
explicit so you know a very simple way
to say is we're going from model of
trust to one of proof so if we see a
paper I know now in science we basically
see well you know which which grew
published this I know that they've been
reliable in the past you know there's
really no reason for that I mean I think
that we have the tools right now there
was a time when paper was scarce it was
difficult to publish everything but now
we actually can communicate all this
information and into the experimental
sciences what you want actually is the
lab notebook because that is the
absolute best record that the researcher
is recording so that they themselves can
repeat their own experiments let me give
you a concrete example of how that can
be used so i'll be talking about
solubility throughout my talk and i'll
i'll give you a reason why a little bit
later but right now let's say that we
have this this table right and we have
all these data points so this is a
solubility of these different compounds
in chloroform and as a chemist something
looks really weird to me because these
compounds are really similar to each
other however one of the numbers is
extremely low point 07 where all the old
ones are at least 1.75 so if this were
if this we're at a table in a journal
what can you do really all you have to
do is say well I guess it's an anomalous
compound well with open notebook science
you can actually ask the question what
is wrong with that particular number so
I will dig in to see how that it
measurement was actually made so
it turned out that that was incorrectly
was reassured at 3.6 which makes a lot
more sense but let's see how I could
actually figure out that there was a
problem so if I go to the actual lab
notebook page where that measurement was
made you see here in green is
highlighted that at nine-thirty they
placed the the violin the speed back and
they removed it at three-thirty so it
spent six hours under a high vacuum and
I know that that's enough to evaporate
the compound that we were just talking
about the other thing you'll notice is
that they did not record the vacuum
pressure they did not record the time
they've or text so it's actually just as
important to know what the the
researcher did not measure as it is then
simply to assume that they did a great
job and they did you know take care of
every parameter so this is the kind of
thing that we want to resolve with open
notebook science so there's a lot of
parts of this just to give you a couple
of examples the other thing is that we
can make the rationale the findings
explicit so I show you the log portion
which is where the researcher records
what they do and what they observe and
then they have to make sense of it right
and so here you know you can see what
this particular research thought and why
they're making the conclusions that they
are and they're linking to raw data and
there and there you know presenting
evidence and the kind of raw data as
Boris said we're not limited anymore
with you know just text so taking
pictures or evaporated samples here's a
couple of interesting things all of
these samples after evaporation look
clean except this one looks like it
might have splattered is that important
I don't know but if there's if there's
an issue with this particular
measurement I probably would want to see
that done again if there's not an issue
with it it might stay there for two or
three years and put you know until we
figure it out but the point is is that
it's available to anyone who wants
access to it you'll notice also the
sample on the left has a little bit of
liquid in it turns out that that's not
actually a very important contribution
to error but it's still really good to
know about it if you see a problem other
kinds of raw data bar I'd mentioned
video I love video because for exactly
the reason that you mentioned is that
even if the student is recording an
experiment they don't necessarily know
what to note down and with the video you
can take 15 seconds just you know record
what
in the experiment the whole set up and
post it on YouTube and I can see where
the thermometer is and that's that could
be an issue maybe that the longer wasn't
in the solution and then you know with
the measurements what do they mean
changes so I love video another thing
that we use quite extensively our google
spreadsheets so these are documents that
are you know totally free totally
available 21 and people can share and
they can add information that can
comment and the really nice thing is
that you can make your calculations
public so if there's a number and I'm
wondering what if there was a problem
with it the first thing i'll do is i
will look at the calculations in the
spreadsheet and it actually tells you
every single measurement when they
weighed the vial when they added to
solve and everything is so if there's
there might be an error in the
calculation maybe they use the wrong
molecular weight that happens all the
time i'm able to make a decision and the
google spreadsheets also has a really
nice feature it has a history so you can
actually go back to a different version
if somebody goes in and changes the
value you can tell that and you can you
can track all that it's very similar to
a wiki so we also use wiki pages as or
actual lab notebook and there as well
every time somebody goes in you can tell
who it is that came in and you can see
when they actually made that change and
so if you're if you're familiar the wiki
basically it's just a program that's
very easy for anyone to come in and edit
it and you have every version and what
you can do is compare two versions so if
we compare one version with the other I
can see in the green here this is the
new stuff that was added and the red
that's the stuff that was deleted so in
this particular case this was a question
that I asked to the student and when
they answered it they deleted my
question so that's actually a very good
way to interact with with students
because you know you can pinpoint
exactly ask them a question and it's a
great way to teach science there's so
much more that we can do with our
technology there is a format called J
camp DX and that will represent any
spectral information that you can plot
on an XY axis and what you
can do is use J spec view which is a
free Java program and you can just
expand any area of the spectrum to zoom
in to see the fine details this is
actually really important this is an NMR
spectrum and what this shows me down
here is that there are actually
impurities in the sample and oftentimes
when you submit to a journal you give
them a PDF and you can't always see
exactly where the impurities are our how
much there are so this is really nice
because you know you don't have to rely
on the author to decide which section to
expand you can go in and expand it and
this is one hundred percent free one
hundred percent open and there's no
programming to learn because it's just
Java it automatically loads on your
browser there's so many other tools as
chemists that we can use chemspider is
one where basically it's a very large
database I'll going to be 22 million
compounds and I can link the compounds
there I can actually add my own data
like it if I measured a melting point I
can add that if I took a spectrum i can
add that and I can also do substructure
searches with in chemspider so instead
of me having to worry about getting a
programmer on my server you know to have
my own customized applications for for
searching the compounds in my lab all I
can do is just put it in chemspider and
let their the experts in storing
chemical information let them worry
about all that stuff and again this is a
free service that's that's very very
useful to us as I said we can we can
upload data we've also started to upload
these non equus all ability measurements
so there's all kinds of things you can
do now when you upload a spectrum in
chemspider it asks you if you want to
make it open data or not and I think a
lot of people when they first see that
question might not realize what's the
difference and why it's important this
is the reason because what we've been
doing now is is took all of the open
data spectrum and we made a game out of
it we have actually a thousand spectra
that basically you have a spectrum
that's given to you and you've got three
molecules this is a collaboration with
Andy Lang and tony williams from
chemspider and basically you just keep
clicking on the right molecule until you
get one wrong so I'm actually giving a
prize right
now to the first student to reach 100
points it's actually a pretty hard game
and these this is what open data means
it's the difference between this and
nothing at all it's very important to
think about it is very important to
think about how maybe someone wants to
use your data in a way that you have
never imagined and don't even want to be
bothered with but it's really important
because you know really useful things
can be done and we've also implemented
this in the Second Life don't have a lot
of time to talk about this but if
anybody is interested I've actually
removed most of my second life slides
because of time constraints but you know
I'd be happy to talk to you about it ok
so let's take this to another level I've
just shown you what happens if you have
one group that's recording their work
what happens if you take this to the
next level and you actually starts to
crowdsource it and that's exactly what
we've done with solubility so in the in
the fall last year started this open
notebook science challenge and the idea
is very simple it's just invite anyone
in the world to take a compound pick an
organic solvent and report the
solubility it turns out that actually
that information you would think would
be widely available and it's not you can
find aqueous solubility fairly easily
you can find the melting point of any
solid out there you can find the boiling
point there's all these properties that
you can find but one of the most
important properties which is I want to
do a reaction in a solvent with solvents
that I choose that's actually pretty
hard to define there are some some
measurements but you won't you won't
find most of them so we've got this
challenge to make this all open people
who can contribute and we share it with
everybody and so there's also some
sponsors that we've got sigma-aldrich
has contributed some free compounds
nature contributed one year subscription
to nature magazine for the first three
winners sub maeda contributed cash
prizes so we've got ten prizes five
hundred dollars each one a month and
we've given out three so far so there's
still seven to give out this year if you
know any students would be interested
any any student in the UK or the u.s. is
eligible so we've had as I had three
three winners we've had Jenny hail from
Southampton killeen Mirza from one of my
students and David Bulger he's at Oral
Roberts University so really spread
across the world and you know this is
working out and so the way that we
actually give out the awards is we have
meetings between judges and the judges
include myself Cameron Ellen rajarshi GU
house a programmer funny Williams is an
NMR expert bill hooker was a molecular
biologist so all these people have
completely different angle towards
science and they're able to evaluate
what the student does how they respond
to their comments and we come to a
decision as to this student you know in
this period of time has probably done
the best job so I think this is a pretty
good model and I've been very happy to
have such high quality people joined it
and again what else can you do with this
was once you have a system in place is
actually not that difficult to take it
to another level so here Brent friesen
from Dominican University just decided
well why don't I make my first week of
sophomore organic chemistry teaching lab
to measure solubilities right he's got
to do it anyway he has to pick he's got
ten weeks he's got to pick certain
experiments to do and he just took the
time to actually do a good job and ask
the students in the first week to
measure any compound in any organic
solvent that they had available and so
then he he up he uploaded those those
data points and we did get some new
measurements so do you imagine actually
being able to leverage this across the
world you know every university has
teaching labs is huge untapped potential
here it just requires the will to
actually implement something different
that you've been doing you know for the
past many years so how do you access the
solubility measurements well one way is
you know through a regular table of
contents that we will look just like
paper you can go to experiment 14 and
you know you can check you can see what
Jenny did but probably a more useful
ways through a database interface so
we've used Google Spreadsheets as a
database and it turns out it does a
really good job so every time we have a
measurement we added to the google
spreadsheet and it has you know this
table is pretty large goes on and on but
the solvent it has information about how
to render that it has information so
that a machine knows that that's a cedar
nitrile it has the link to the notebook
and everything and Google actually has a
visualization API that is really nice so
you can actually treat a Google
spreadsheet like a real database and you
can do queries like any pic of solvent
to pick a solute or pick a solubility
range and it will return exactly what
you asked so this is actually a really
neat way to query this and the important
thing here is that this is live data if
a student does a measurement in the next
hour and they put it here and you do a
search later tonight this is live so
should you trust that number or not well
again it comes down to being able to go
all the way back through the chain of
provenance so if you look at for example
vandala in methanol these numbers should
all be the same because it's the same
compound in the same solvent but they're
not their differences so if you want to
investigated see maybe one of those
experiments wasn't done properly at the
bottom of the page there's a link to the
lab notebook page and you can go in and
you can figure out I will include this
or I will not included and lately we've
also been able to do substructure
searching which is pretty cool so it
means that if i want to ask the question
all the analogs of 4-hydroxyphenyl de
hide give me their solubility I can do
that by using what's called the smarts
and so this is actually really it's it's
quite a powerful database when you think
about it all kinds of things we can do
if there any chemists in the audience if
you're doing drug development you've
probably seen these these charts where
you can take two molecular descriptors
then you can plot in this case R
applauding solubility if you were
developing the drug you would plot
activity assay results but you can
actually explore the chemical space and
again this is all live this is all done
live off that Google spreadsheet could
also do the same thing in second life
and you got an extra dimension to play
with ok so again i really want to drill
this home this this whole concept of
provenance so what do we do with this
information well if you know about that
little website you can go in and you can
use the drop downs and find your
compound what if you don't well we've
started to add
from wikipedia so if you go to the
benzoic acid entry you'll see now that
there's an entry for solubility well
there's always that's always been an
entry for solubility in water like I
said that's pretty commonly available
but now there's an entry solubility in
and then the solvents will vary
depending on what we've done but that
link actually takes you to this it takes
it to this page which shows you all the
solvents all the concentrations gives
you the standard deviation for each one
and then if you want to drill down and
look specifically for example methanol
it will give you these five measurements
and then if you click on one of these
columns it will take you to the lab
notebook page and if you click on this
it will take you to the Google
spreadsheet with the actual numbers of
the scale exactly what was measured so
this is what I'm talking about with
provenance basically you can track
everything and we can even include links
literature we were talking earlier lunch
about the google books this is great I
mean once they're out of copyright you
don't have to worry about how people are
going to access it anyone in the world
now can just click on a link and the
nice thing about solubility it's a
pretty simple measurement so you know a
lot of it's been done 100 years ago
unfortunately they didn't finish it but
they did actually do a lot so I can
actually link I can make one of the
references just another data point mixed
in with all the lab notebook pages so
now you can compare things and you can
see what's making sense and what's not
we also have if you also include
temperature our little this ain't and
allowing built this it will basically
give you the the curves of temperature
so this we want to do in the future once
we get a lot more people we want to get
you know a lot more temperature
measurements and again second life we
can explore solubility this is kind of a
neat Explorer if you click here on the
different aldehydes and you stand on
these it's like an elevator the higher
the solubility is higher you go you can
you can see over you know different
solvent systems where the different
components are going to be soluble we're
not going to be soluble I know a lot of
time today but that's basically the idea
behind this to be able to control
chemical reactions and control when they
precipitate so the better we can
visualize these things you know the be
easier the chemistry is ok I want to
talk a little bit about
this useful chem project that was
mentioned earlier so again this is open
notebook science this is prior to the
solubility work and the idea here is we
want to make new anti-malarial compounds
so this represents a collaboration
between computational people
specifically rajarshi go hide indiana
university he does docking so so is he
basically we have a library of compounds
with we want to know which ones are most
likely to inhibit an enzyme he tells us
we make them and then we ship them off
Phil Rosenthal UCSF does the acid as he
tests them so basically you have all the
three components you have the theory you
have the synthesis and then you have the
assays and that's really that's what you
need to go through a full cycle of drug
development and we're working on the
falsa pain to enzyme recently so the way
that we spread these out I've already
shown you some of these components
alright I've definitely show you the
wiki I've shown you the google docs but
some of these other things i'm going to
show you in just a minute and we can
also use a blog right so how do we use a
blog well when we started this project
the idea was one experiment one blog
post well that really didn't work out
very well because what happens is that
the experiment you know keeps getting
updated and then the student writes a
discussion and then and as errors you
fix it so it turns out into the problem
with the blog post is you can change all
that but you can't track it so you can't
tell the things were changed so that's
why we shipped you know without that's
that's why we change to a wiki but the
blog is still really useful for giving
you know milestone information to people
about our project and what we do here is
we basically you know discuss something
and then we click on a link so it says
see experiment 150 that takes us to the
lab notebook page you've seen in this
format right and the one thing I didn't
show you earlier is you can show you can
actually put stuff that is not just
synthetic chemistry this is the docking
results that rajarshi did so you can
actually track exactly the way that
rajarshi did the calculations and if you
did it the same way you should end up
with the same
most the compounds in the same order so
we want to make really everything
reproducible and so it turns out that
we've identified four compounds that are
reasonably active against malaria and
against the files being too enzyme and
those results can be put in another
database called collaborative drug
discovery CDD and here if you're looking
for assays for four different diseases
that's another place so to see every
different kind of information has its
own natural place to aggregate to okay
one last concept that i want to bring
across here so where does that put
traditional publications because i
haven't talked about that yet I've just
talked about there's a notebook so
here's a project where we have this
reaction we want to optimize it so we're
going to vary the concentration in the
solvent Texas of some of the reagents
we're going to write a paper on this so
we wrote the paper on a wiki open to the
world in real time so all the drafts are
there and the really nice thing about
having a lab notebook that's open is I
can actually say the melting point for
this compound was obtained from
experiment 99 but it's h-nmr was
obtained from experiment 203 that's a
little simplification that gets made in
papers it says we made this compound and
we did these measurements that's not
really true usually they might have made
several batches so here you are actually
referring to the specific batch so
there's a problem down the line you can
you can track it back so what we also
did is we submitted that paper to a
peer-reviewed journal and borrows
mentioning journal visualized
experiments I think so this is where you
there's a video portion and there's also
a written portion so the written portion
obviously was we were on the wiki and
then so we got this paper accepted and
as the paper was under peer review we
also posted it on nature proceedings
which is a preprint site so the nice
thing about that is that you know we can
actually talk about this article we can
talk about everything in it I can give
people author lists a DOI all of it and
then it gets published and Jove that's
great and at no point in time that I
have to you know that I wasn't able to
give people an open Oh
open link to my work so basically you
know who's doing this kind of thing so
there's here's 30 pin notebooks like to
share with you Gus lasagnas work he's at
Michigan he does drug transport both
measuring and theoretical camera nailin
also he's got some great presentations
if you have if you're interested in open
notebook science definitely check out
his videos so he uses a modified blog
engine so that you can in fact see the
tracking so it's a little bit different
than our system and a recent addition on
open what were actually Anthony Solveig
knows he's basically just started a
couple weeks ago and he really has been
putting everything he's doing up on
there so that that's been really nice to
see and obviously he's doing some
molecular biology here and I think I
mentioned most of these people might
talk and that's it I should start by
echoing the thanks to the organizers and
Catherine Pope in particular for
inviting me down here and I'm setting
everything up it's been a fun visit so
far and I'm going to talk about some I'm
going to talk about some of my own
experiences with open science during the
course of my PhD and some of the
initiatives that we started at MIT and I
may forget to note this explicitly on a
few occasions but I think you'll see
there's a lot of common themes between
what both Bora and jean-claude have
previously talked about so
so I'm going to talk about my own
specific experiences so it makes sense
to talk a little bit about about what I
did so I'm going to give some
definitions and this is a sort of a
limited definition of myself I'm a
synthetic biologist is the sort of work
I do I'm now with the startup King
caballo works and I've also been
involved a lot with open wetware org
which I'll talk about a little bit later
and so I want to explain just very
briefly what synthetic biology is and
synthetic biology is a new discipline we
and its goal is to design and build
novel biological systems aided by an
engineering infrastructure so to split
that sentence up into two parts we're
designing and building novel biological
systems for example we'd like to
reprogram bacteria to produce biofuels
drugs or other valuable chemicals and
we'd like to do it through the use of an
engineering infrastructure and what that
means is that rather than trying to
engineer bacteria in a sort of an ad hoc
fashion as it has been the the standard
in genetic engineering and metabolic
engineering and disciplines we'd like to
use something more similar to the way
electrical engineering works where
there's a lot of use of standardization
parts and computer-aided design tools
and we'd like to try and introduce some
of those kind of tools into the
discipline of engineering biology so
that's the kind of stuff that we've been
trying to do and the last concept I want
to introduce is this concept of parts
and parts are essentially pieces of DNA
that encodes some sort of basic
biological function and if you take a
bunch of parts and you put them together
and you put them together in the right
order and you can use at that set of
parts to reprogram a bacteria to do
something interesting so that's sort of
that the means that we that we follow to
try and make a cells do new and
interesting things but we have some
problems in this new discipline the
first problem is that this idea of
biological parts which we call BioBricks
they don't currently exist so we have to
invent them and we have to invent a
means to describe them and it means to
share them so they
can be easily reused by by other people
the second problem we have is that a lot
of people who are attracted to synthetic
biology our engineers computer
scientists and people from backgrounds
other than biology and I was a
mechanical engineer originally and that
means that we don't we typically don't
have the sort of the training both
practical and in the classroom about a
lot of that sort of standard molecular
biology techniques so we have these we
have these two problems I think the
second problem is sort of an interesting
extension of what boero was talking
about earlier where you have you have
the problem where because information
has been sort of localized and hard to
get access to if you're if you are at a
non-major resourcing institution it's
it's hard to get access to that
information there's another problem
where even people who are at major
research institutions if they're trying
to change the sort of the discipline
that they're they're working on or
they're trying to apply their technology
to some new field it's hard to learn
about that new field so it's sort of
this general problem of information
being constrained and forward a nice job
of explaining how we're moving away from
from that so I'm going to talk about
solutions to these two problems the
first solution that it came out of MIT a
little bit before i got there was at the
registry of standard biological parts so
this is a website which is essentially a
catalog of his early collections of
these biobrick parts that we've been
making people at MIT and people at other
institutions and it's sort of modeled on
the Texas Instruments electronic device
catalogs and kind of the 70s and 80s
where you could go and look up a
particular transistor or a capacitor or
an inverter circuit and so this is a
website that's your free and open and
editable and it's it's a sort of a
combination of a database in a wiki
where you can add parts you can describe
the parts that you've made you can
comment on other people's parts all that
sort of wiki functionality under the
registry of standard biological parks as
well as being a way to share that
information it's also maintains a
physical collection of those DNA parts
and it distributes those two people who
need
them sort of a joint information and
physical material distribution on
catalog and I'm going to tell you just
two short anecdotes related to this
registry of standard biological parts
the first is is one of these parts that
I was working on during my PhD at part
number B baf 2620 it's a it's a very
simple little part that basically just
lets bacterial cells talk to each other
it's like the receiver in your radio or
cell phone and it's not very interesting
everybody knows how the biology and the
science of this works but it's very very
useful and the only problem is that the
traditional means of sharing information
about about something like this is
through the published literature and it
the journals tend not to celebrate small
pieces of information that aren't
enormous new exciting discoveries so the
the means we chose to to share our
description of this of this part that we
had engineered was via a data sheet this
is the data sheet for BBA f2 620 and we
did a bunch of measurements on how this
part behaves and we put them on this
data sheet and its intended to be
presented in a form it's hard to see
here but it's intended to be presented
in a form that if someone comes along
and wants to use this part all the
information is contained on this data
sheet so they can use it and I'm not
sort of different from having to troll
the literature to find out everything
that you might need to know about apart
this is sort of a summary of this part
and how you how you need to go about
using it and while we were taking all
these measurements this data sheet was
evolving it was it was online it was
both on the registry of sound obliged
biological parts and I was also on open
wetware which I'm going to talk about
later so we were putting all the data up
as we were as we were taking it I'm not
sure I don't think we were as as
diligent and detailed as Jean Claude
described and that was really nice to
see but basically once it once we had
data it went up on the on the wiki and
was was available to people to use and
so eventually we ended up publishing the
this work in a in a sort of a
traditional Journal
and but we were able to include a pretty
interesting sentence that where portion
of it is here and we said that we made
freely available the DNA encoding bbiaf
2620 and its data sheet via the registry
was town of biological parts already 18
higher order systems incorporating the
receiver which bbiaf 2620 have been
contributed back to the registry and
that's sort of unusual in a traditional
publishing system whereby the first
people get to see of your work is when
it appears in the journal where if we
were able to write in the paper we've
already been sharing the information and
the physical DNA for this part and
people have been using it and it's
useful and we found we felt that that
made the paper a much stronger much
stronger document we were already able
to say that this is a useful this is a
useful object and unluckily that is sort
of more traditional publishing house was
was very open to to have publishing
stuff that was actually already
available online and a second nanak DOTA
i want to tell is them about something
called the iGEM competition this is an
undergraduate summer competition where
teams from around the world compete to
engineer a novel biological system
that's the most exciting they can they
can do and this is a picture of some of
the teams who attended the sort of that
the Jamboree at the end of the
competition last summer at MIT there's a
total of seventy teams of undergraduates
around the world who worked on this
during the summer and and everything
they do they do in the open all the
parts that they make they have to
contribute back to the registry all
their their lab notebooks are stored on
on a wiki that's run by the the I gem
organization and they do everything
basically in the open and and this might
be a good time to
show you one of those and I think this
is interesting because this is us this
is an undergraduate comp it's a
competition and it's it's research
they're doing they're doing new work but
engineered into the competition is is a
sort of a pressure to be open so for
example there's there's prizes for who
who has the best lab notebook and wiki
at the at the end of the competition and
so it's a it's a it's a it's a
competition that has been sort of
engineered to to provide incentives to
people who want to share information
earlier and so that's sort of an
interesting that's interesting because
the sort of the current reward structure
in science does not reward yeah are
often does not reward people being open
or they at least they think it doesn't
and so here's a here's an example this
is the this is the winning wiki from
from last year you can see there's
information about the team there's the
calendar of what they did when the parts
they made and contributed back pictures
you can they have a lab notebook where
you can click on particular dates and
I'm sort of picking this at random looks
like that was a bad day in the lab see
that's right here and yeah so they've
kept a lot of their data online I didn't
pick a particular page to show but on
some pages you'll see they have sort of
like gel images and all their data
available so anyway this is it this is a
group of about a thousand undergraduates
every summer who are being trained to do
open science and to be celebrated for
doing that so I think that's a pretty
pretty powerful story some of them there
so that kind of gets us onto onto wiki's
and and that was the next thing I wanted
to talk about so open wetware is a wiki
you heard it introduced to the start
it's to promote sharing information
among biological and biological
engineers and we started this at MIT
because even within our lab we had
problems sharing as much information as
we wanted between each other so we said
okay we'll have a lab wiki and we'll
we'll share information this was back in
in early 2005 and then we decided well
there's a there's a lot we collaborate
with across the at the other end of MI
to campus and we'd like to share
information with them because they do
the same stuff as us so they came on and
then you know a couple of the labs jet
down the hall also found it would be
useful and they joined as well and sort
of spread organically like that and
quickly spread outside of MIT and at
this point there's about 150 labs on
open wet where there is over five
thousand registered users and so let me
just give you an idea of what what what
open wetware is there's a lot of
different things on it so open where has
a lot of different content one of the
things that has is a lot of people keep
their their lab websites on there so
this is the croissant ylab from the from
Imperial you can see there's information
about who's in the lab their
publications have pictures they keep a
lot of technical information on here
what restriction enzymes they use their
their chemicals how to do ordering all
those kind of low levels sort of things
that that make a lab work so we open
wetware provides it easy for people to
share that sort of information within
their groups and they also keep
descriptions of their of their research
online so you see a lot of things like
that there's also a collection of
protocols and that are edited by the
community people contribute them and so
for example escherichia coli there's a
whole set of protocols that have been
contributed by scientists from all
around the world and edited by other
scientists the goal to come up with sort
of refined very reliable lab protocols
that everybody can use and and this was
really helpful to us when we got started
because we we were a group of people
doing research that we hadn't been
trained to do in some sense because we
were spending a lot of time doing
likelier biology so to have groups come
on here contribute their protocols and
their information and made our lives a
lot easier and I I hope it's making the
lives easier for other groups who are
getting started on new sets of
experiments something else I'd show
there's also a lot of courses and I mean
it's a wiki and see you can use open
where for whatever you want
if people keep courses this is a course
run by by Steve Koch who who's on Claude
mentioned has a student who has a nice
open science lab notebook now and but he
keeps all the information about this
course and the interactions with the
with the students online you know they
can comment they can correct things they
can download the slides they need so
it's been a pretty powerful resource for
courses and there's about 10 or 15
courses on their item oment and the last
page and I could show you from open
wetware is M is the e.coli genotypes
page so this this page started because
one scientist was annoyed about how I'm
am i doing on time is that and this page
started because scientists at MIT was
annoyed about eco like genotype
information which is essentially codes
to describe a particular strain of E
coli and it's it's very hard to navigate
so it was started by a scientist and
then other people started to contribute
to it and it's now if you search for any
sort of combination of e.coli and
genotypes or anything like that on
Google it's the first thing that comes
up and it's become a really useful
resource for a lot of people and it's
been noticed as such so if you look here
on the left you can see a list of
contributing authors so a lot of these
people are sort of people that I've you
know worked with at MIT their grad
students and technicians and labs but
there's also people who have suddenly
started editing this page like John
works who maintains the Yale ecoli stock
center and there's Mary Ross who also
works there there's Peter carp who works
at the bio bio psych which maintains a
large database of all interactions
within ecoline and so suddenly a lot of
professors and people who work on
databases are coming to a page like this
and nucleating around it and and adding
a lot of really helpful information here
and so that that's a sort of a
whistle-stop tour of open wetware and i
need to i need to move on and adjust
some statistics on open wet where we get
about four million
hits a month about a hundred thousand of
which are unique visits we've over 5,000
registered users and a lot of our pages
are extremely highly ranked by Google
and so this is this isn't open science
in a really pure sense where where
you're sharing every single piece of
information that you that you do but
it's a people are sharing the
information that they there ready to an
unhappy to share and it's been very
useful to a lot of people and so one
thing I wanted to finish up with an idea
that that actually Bora sort of touched
on and which was that you know over time
there's been this democratization of
access to information you know from from
Newton and his book that no one could
get access to all the way to everyone
can start a blog and share information
today there's also been a
democratization of fabrication which is
sort of happening more recently so
everyone now has a printer on their on
their desk they can they can print out
whatever text they want the next thing
that that's coming down the line are 3d
printers that you have on your desk so
you can you can rapidly prototype a 3d
object and have it on your have it on
your bench and the exact same thing is
happening in biology so we have a
rapidly increasing ability to write
sequences of DNA and the reason I bring
up this democratization of fabrication
is that it means that information is
becoming critical if you have access to
to the information you need to do
something you probably have the tools to
make it or make it happen so a sort of a
striking example of this was about in
2005 the the complete genome sequence
for the 1918 flu was published and quite
shortly after a second paper was
published this one here in science where
they had they synthesized that that
genome the flu genome and they they they
got it work and they basically booted up
that that that virus and they showed
that the virus has the app has the
ability to replicate in the absence of
trypsin cause death in mice and
embryonated chicken eggs and displayed a
high growth phenotype in human bronchial
epithelial
cells basically they made the most one
of the most the worst pandemic viruses
that we've had in our history and they
showed that it worked and and why were
they able to do that they were able to
do that because someone had had shared
the information of the of the DNA
sequence and once that was out there it
was easy to make this and do it so so I
bring this issue up because if you can
share information you can people will
start doing a lot of things that are
either good or good or bad and there's a
number of different ways we can choose
to to deal with that the first is you
could say if you're going to do
something like if you want to do
something like share the sequence of of
the part of the 19 18 flu you shouldn't
do that that's going to be regulated
it's going to happen in a federal lab or
a second approach is you can say which
is what we do now we say you can do that
work and then you have to publish it in
a in an academic journal so the
information only gets out after the
event has happened after someone has
made the flu virus third approach is
that if people were adhering to the sort
of an open science approach and they
were discussing their work as they
planned it and as it happened then
people would be able to to comment on
work like this where people are making
dangerous flus and would be able to
either decide how to respond to it or
whether to to try and get these people
to do something different and but so
that's it that's another that's another
option the current option is that nobody
talks about anything until after they've
done it and that can be that can be a
dangerous thing so that's all I wanted
to say and just to summarize open
science can work it's worked in my own
case and that might not always be true
I've been I've been lucky in that I work
in a discipline where where it's
relatively accepted and finally
information distribution is becoming
increasingly consequential because once
you have the information you can do a
lot of things so thank you very much I
noticed that most of you have google
products in your lineup of ways to be
for your solutions and you're talking
about information being open personally
how do you feel about Google
presence with holding information and
how that's going to interact with your
hope to open up science ever think about
Google you well experiencing yeah I mean
I i love google i mean google is
permitted us to do things that otherwise
you know would have been very expensive
to do i mean the reason that i use those
specific tools is because i want if
anyone's interested in any part of what
we're doing that overnight they can
replicate it and so if we use a Google
spreadsheet I know for a fact that that
will scale we can get you know you can
use it immediately Google's been pretty
good overall I mean the you know
recently there was the Google research
stocks that was supposed to happen and
they didn't that's unusual I mean
usually you know that they keep
improving it but again you know these
these documents if down the road Google
decides of not continue Google
Spreadsheets doesn't really concern me I
mean basically we can move it over to
another platform and at that point you
know if we have to buy something we'll
do it but i don't i think that the trend
is to have more companies make available
these kinds of platforms for free rather
than going backwards I don't know what
you guys think yeah I mean we we use
Google Spreadsheets a lot as well not in
quite a sophisticated away but we found
them really really helpful as a as a
tool in our lab and so for the moment
we're trusting them
thank you very much for the presentation
I enjoyed the presentation but I have a
fundamental question about whether these
projects are scalable to being the core
of mainstream science I mean it seems to
me that I'm not an economist if there's
one here I'd appreciate his comments on
this but it seems to me that currently
the economic infrastructure of science
is based on the holding of private
information by competitive agents in a
large science marketplace that competes
for funding and I don't understand how
this system is I mean you would little
what you're talking about is to subvert
the entire funding distribution system
of science I mean it's by quite more so
it may be much more subversive than you
realize yes this is very subversive what
the different areas of science are
responding to this differently because
of limited resources how easy it is to
replicate somebody else's work so I
think and what are the possible rewards
is patent money fame Nobel prizes stuff
like that so the the secretiveness is
the greatest in areas where it's easy to
scoop and where the rewards are
potentially really big where expense of
doing stuff is big and where there is a
lot of competition think cancer research
they're not going to say anything to
anybody but there are other areas which
are much more open let's say ecology you
have already ten seasons of studying
white-tailed deer in your corner of the
forest who is going to scoop you and you
don't see their tent in that corner and
you're ten years ahead of them much
easier to share much easier to do
something like open science because you
don't really have competition you can be
scooped and there's no but no Nobel
Prize for ecology so then you know then
you have something in between like
dinosaur paleontology five and a half
people have the money to do it but once
you go to some you know god-awful place
to dig it everybody knows you're there
nobody's going to scoop you you can
absolutely freely take pictures of your
fossil as you're digging it out every
day and nobody can do anything about it
you can be scooped you're the one who
dug it up so different areas are going
to be different about it so I think it's
going to go in different rates the
adoption of some or all of these opening
kind of ideas or ways of doing stuff are
going to be adopted different rates in
different areas of science yeah and you
bring a couple of different issues in
terms of funding I think it's actually
very good for funding I mean the last
funding that I got was precisely because
of being open on one of our networks
friendfeed and you know we've been
publishing our proposals and other
people have been doing Steve Koch's and
other one who's been publishing his
proposals you know and that attracts
collaborators i don't i don't think that
the federal agencies are going to look
down at you know sharing fact i think
it's going to be positive now where
there might be an issue is in the
intellectual property sphere and I
definitely agree you I don't think you
can both pursue at least at mica is open
notebook science and intellectual
property you have to make a decision but
that's nothing new I mean when you
decide to publish a paper and not file a
patent or provisional patent or whatever
you want you've made a decision so
you're just making it earlier in the
process and so the Boris said it's
different areas i work in malaria
specifically for that reason I then work
in malaria before I did open science
totally different I'm doing that because
it's a project that it makes a lot of
sense to be open about the solubility
project again I think it's a very good
area because it's easy to do people can
share it and everybody can benefit so I
think you know instead of you you might
end up collaborating with someone who
might be your competitor in another
world I think that's that's what we're
finding let me give you a related but
different experience I'm not in the lab
anymore
being in like five or six years anymore
that doesn't mean my mind is not a
scientific mind anymore I have ideas I
just don't have a lab to do that about
three three-and-a-half years ago I
posted a hypothesis on my blog ok look
ok if anybody's interested you know you
have resources go do it I really like to
see this hypothesis test it is no way I
can do it i'm blogging and writing and
doing other stuff i don't have a lab
well three years three and a half years
passed and i get an email out of the
blue from you know Cornell we would like
to test your hypotheses I said go ahead
just the you know once it's published
just so let the people know where the
hypothesis come from I would like to see
my name in print as much as that and
said no no we want to collaborate with
you will do the field work you analyze
the data and we write a paper asset yeah
of course I mean why not I can do that
yeah I think we've seen similar sort of
things where we're being open has has
led to new collaborations and new
connections with people from other from
people who have a different skill set
than you and that that those
collaborations can lead to you know very
traditional forms of academic reward you
know like like papers and funding open
wetware for example has a million
dollars in NSF funding so that the
traditional structure is certainly open
to these sort of ideas I would say are
increasingly so at least thanks
everybody this has been great i'm really
enthusiastic about all this and i'm
going to throw in this wild concept that
this all goes back to Marshall McLuhan
and the medium is the message the reason
science is changing is because the
distribution mechanisms for information
have changed none of you addressed what
I think is probably the weakest part of
contemporary science which is the review
process in fact what I've seen is that
people don't have time to do adequate
peer review and they don't have the
motivation to do adequate peer review
and that
one has the experience of submitting
hard work to peer review and getting
reviews back that make no sense and
having very little recourse and I wonder
if there if any of you have any ideas as
to how the existence of this new
bi-directional communication medium will
change the way things move from informal
hypothetical science to formal
peer-reviewed science yeah I mean I'm
sure you have a lot to say that for me
it all comes down to the proof versus
trust if you give enough proof you don't
really need peer review for what you
think your people think they submit to
peer review and everything that gets put
in that paper gets carefully analyzed
and we know that that's not the case but
instead of that if you make people
actually give in full details all the
proof then at a time in the future when
someone tries to repeat it or someone
tries to use it then they'll be able to
go and find it no one's going to be
going through every little piece of
detail during the part of the submission
so yeah we didn't talk of much of a peer
review I mean pirius really compatible
with open notebook science now you have
to choose your publishers not
necessarily yet has to be a publisher
that will accept preprints luckily there
are enough that you know it makes sense
in most fields and yes and that's one of
the important parts of what we talked
about at plus headquarters every day
because it's a it it's a big deal so
asking for raw data asking for you know
videos and stuff like that helps our
reviewers review review better because
hopefully they'll you know run the
simulations themselves or something like
that it's probably not going to happen
all the time but they're going to do is
just the first level or first layer or
review but then as time passes and em
people try to replicate or build upon
those papers if something doesn't work
that's why we have those comments and no
so 20 years from now somebody comes back
to one of our papers they're not going
to trust it just because it was
published in plos they're going to read
a paper but they're going to reach 20
years of comments and notes additions
corrections that they're going to then
see how much that paper can be trusted
because of this whole post publication
peer review which right now happens
behind closed doors in the lab offices
as meetings corridors is going to be
made public so over time people will see
how much to trust each paper
No
just be cloud Lee it's all right 12 oh
okay good my follow-up is that you still
didn't address the the key is that
careers advance on the basis of
publication now I can blog until my head
falls off but that's still not going to
advance how I look on paper and it's the
functionality of other people officially
saying that I've done something valuable
that's actually the whole enterprise is
the whole scientific enterprise is based
on that and so my question is not just
the value of what goes out there you've
made a very good case for that but how
the validation will occur so that
essentially so the grant agencies have
better information as to who's actually
you know doing good work and who's just
pranking our papers this is the problem
of living in a age of transition where
you have simultaneously two generations
i'm going to say generation don't mean
age I mean mindset a secretive versus
open and they're going to clash and that
also means how you evaluate the quality
of contributions of others is going to
be very different in these two parallel
words and it's happening everywhere
where where Internet is having the
effect look at journalism newspapers are
dying left and right who what is
trustworthy source anymore somebody who
was on the Denver fly that had a trouble
taking off twittering hey I was just in
an air crash or the journalist who a day
later said hey there was a crash in
Denver that's what CNN said and so I'm
copying and pasting so these kinds of
questions are not solved I don't have
the answer to a question right now but I
think as the generational
kind of switch happens that all of these
contributions that are outside of just
okay I'm publishing in science nature
and plus biology and so I'm brilliant
that all these other aspects of
contribution to science are going to be
evaluated in some way because it's going
to be evaluated by the same people who
are doing it themselves kind of the
Facebook generation is going to be
judging the Facebook generation not
they're not you know the oldsters
judging the Facebook generation so I
think there will be a system evolving
over the next 10 years 20 years that is
going to then settle down into something
that works I hope I think I think I see
evidence of that in my field already for
example and if you're a graduate student
there would be graduate students who
could get postdocs postdoc positions in
top labs in top universities based not
on their publication record but based on
their their record in something like the
iGEM competition advising undergraduates
or contributions of their own parts and
materials to the to the registry of
parts and or activity on on email
threads and mailing lists between
faculty and students so that's up there
kind of graduate to post doc level when
those postdocs end up on faculty hiring
committees and pretty much as Boris said
I expect that they're going to take into
account much more than just a number of
publications but in the meantime keep
publishing in traditional journals that
this doesn't really stop it it just just
affects a little bit of who where you
send your stuff too but no I agree i
think in fact is it's exactly the
reverse is going to happen is gonna be
dangerous not to be open at some point
because you're going to lose visibility
i mean you know once you start doing
it's so obvious that is the right thing
to do for finding people that right now
you're right it's not we're not there
you're losing these ability are going to
lose credibility I mean I go back to
facebook everybody's nervous or you're
putting you know your pictures of you
know drunken parties on Facebook and
when you're you know opt for a job and
that
hire you you're in trouble yes because
the people who are hiring are not the
Facebook generation 20 years from now if
you don't have drunken party party
pictures of facebook if you're suspect
you are you are embellishing your
profile too much that's going to be
suspicious it's like everybody has those
pictures where are yours what are you
hiding and I think that's going to
happen in science as well why weren't
you open why were you hiding alright
this is kind of a kind of along a
similar event sorry perhaps seems a
little bit redundant but I think many of
the concerns about open access
publishing and it's already been
mentioned one specifically revolve
around tenure and how academics in the
university setting view open access
publishing as a credible record of your
research etc and you know I personally
don't have to worry about this for
another forty-eight years but I'm
writing an article and this I was
wondering if I could get your
perspectives and any situations you've
run into or if you have any other
opinions well I work for an open-access
journals I'm assuming the questions for
me I ok let's say right now the the work
is you know your scientific output is
measured by in which journal you
published it's not going to happen in
two years that's going to be gone but
right now it is that this situation so
you're looking okay well I'm publishing
in nature or science or whichever
journal you can publish your stuff in it
doesn't matter if it's open access or
not the the facts if that journal is
open access is not has nothing to say
about the quality of the journal or
quality of science in it
and yeah you know people that there are
enemies of open access because there are
people who are making a lot of money on
keeping things close and they are very
good at disseminating disinformation
open access has nothing to do with
quality open access has to do it open
it's the same paper in this journal or
than that journal can be enough for pay
or can be free so I don't think you know
you know it's not just that I work for
plaza have to do my PR but you know I go
around one of my job's is to you know is
to observe what blogosphere is saying
about science and publishing and about
us the boss and to me it makes sure it
is so so I've been in tune for a couple
of years at least and what people are
saying so well you know you need to
publish in science nature pause biology
what signs nature applause biology and
you're doing good for tenure sense
Boston Globe og or sale or you know
there's three or four journals show up
one of them is open access and nobody
gives it you know nobody nobody gives
any question well one of them is open
access and the others or not those are
quality journals and that's what is
accepted internationally everywhere does
the journals that you have to publish in
if you are in these very competitive
fields and you want to get a job at
Columbia or Harvard or MIT if you want
to work it NC State milam you know
you're fine in some other journals in a
few years when you know different
measurement you know evaluation systems
get developed an impact factor dies then
you won't even matter where you
published your paper because your paper
individual papers are going to have
their own measures and the tenure
committees are going to look at the
measures of your papers and other
journals in which you publish them well
the committee's are also looking at your
reputation which is based partially on
your public
in different journals but also based on
your activities in the community so I
think that's where it comes down to i
mean the the recommendation letters of
recommendation and what people will say
i think that factor is very strongly of
course if you have no papers and you
have great reputation that's not going
to work but if you have some minimum
number and you have a great reputation
that's really where the thing comes
together but yeah bored i'm actually
something really interesting which is
the miscommunication about open access i
mean there are people who still think
that you know open access means there's
no peer review and it has nothing to do
you know with it so i think part of it
is you know we have to keep going out
and repeating the message what you do
for sure and you know i think people
will get it it's just a question of
using it and you know handing your paper
over that you publish and open access
and they're very addictive because once
you've got it as open access journal you
know you can share with anybody and then
you go back to one of your older
publications and you can't do that it's
really annoying so once people start to
experience it I think makes sense is
this is a graduate program process I
think it's going actually fostered and
people who started the open access
movement have been envisioned I think I
think scientists are in generally did
they might not know they don't know
exactly how to go about it but I think
they viscerally like the idea of
openness and are receptive to the
message they can hear it once did I have
to repeat 30 tons for every person to to
show them the benefits of publishing it
open access journals or depositing in in
institutional repositories this you know
it sounds all in theory very nice and
utopian and and equina tech equitable
and everything but I I still would like
to it seems to me from what you're
saying that open access there are
certain fields that are lend themselves
more to open access than others and that
as this progresses you know there will
be certain areas that go that way in
certain areas that continue
you know in the old tradition now you
know one of the things I'm thinking
about is there's a lot of collaborations
between universities and companies and
obviously there's where you're going to
have your real secrecy is there a
utopian vision of any changes in that
that could open that up is that possible
or I mean this is going a bit far afield
but you know I'm just curious if you
guys have any ideas about that yes will
I we are you know if if you read talking
we are the open access gnaws drool but I
have to say something open access
especially open notebook science what
they're doing is not for everybody there
are situations where this is not an
advisable thing and that is for instance
you know are in the defense things like
that no you want to keep those things
secret i mean its government research
we're building on your rocket you don't
do open notebook science on that and
that's fine and they're going to be
other kind of in between cases so we're
trying to push those people who are in
the areas that should profit from doing
it openly but we understand i think you
agree that there are areas which for
which that is just not the appropriate
way to go yeah i mean i would even say
that you know i don't foresee mainstream
science becoming open notebook I don't
see that at all but the beauty of it is
is that you'll need a very small
fraction of scientists to actually do it
to gain the benefit and that's really
what we're shooting for is to not
necessarily convert people but to find
people who recognize that eight you know
I'd like to do this but I don't have
time to figure out how so show me how
and then we have the how now it's just a
question of doing it see the nice thing
that happens especially with open
notebook science is that the day that
the experiment gets done everyone knows
about it so a stranger could come and
pick up your project that very same day
and that's really why I keep making such
a
emphasis on this concept because if you
if you delayed your notebook by six
months you lose pretty much most of the
advantage it's at that point when I
think we're going to start to see
machines collaborating with machines on
a very very rapid basis if you can read
and write for free on a platform then
you can start to think about these
things but no you absolutely need to
have mainstream science become that in
people who have their livelihood
dependent on patents obviously can't do
that at all that's fine yeah yeah I mean
I'm my experience I've transitioned from
an academic community that you know kind
of viscerally supported like open access
to information and now I'm working at a
company and we've had to accept the fact
that that if we're going to stay in
business and make money than there are
things that we have to keep key
proprietary and keep to ourselves so I
think yeah it's just different solutions
were different for different groups even
within science or if it changes it's not
going to be very soon it's going to be
50 or 100 years science fiction kind of
it with technological changes you might
get to the point where it's fine for
government to build new weapon and do it
openly and nobody can do anything about
it because there's still the fastest
they started first well obviously there
there are issues of national security
and things like that where you
absolutely you know secrecy isn't even a
question but something like the
pharmaceutical companies which fall into
the ethical gray area because if you're
trying to develop a drug for malaria
obviously for the good of the millions
and millions of people who are dying
from it it pays to collaborate it would
be wonderful to have everything out in
the open yeah um and this is a huge
debate within the pharmaceutical you
know science area
and my question was more towards those
gray areas rather than you know the
obvious areas where you know national
security would be compromised so you're
you're by the sign of you're probably
familiar with some of the things the
pharmaceutical industry has been doing
where they've been declaring certain
pieces of information to be
pre-competitive and they prefer to just
have them out and open and share it
between everybody I think it was the
library of sniff data that the sum of
the big companies decide what we should
just share this with everyone so you do
see some examples of that I think and I
think solubility falls in that area too
that's something that all companies get
benefit from and it's so general that
they couldn't really gain any
competitive advantage so yeah and you
know there was some discussion of this
at cyclic shear it becomes a couple
sessions where the you know there
because each each company is spending
all this money doing the same thing and
it's not necessarily competitive so yeah
probably not but I drove it probably not
that you stood there maybe they would
survive today it's just another level
level concept yeah but I'm assuming
they're pretty good at reverse
engineering Toyota's so figuring out how
they work so they can build something
better maybe I hope
open culture
but over the parts culture that you were
talking about yeah yeah i mean the the
sort of that the parts culture that grew
up around electric i like electronic
engineering you still have to pay for
access to things but but but things
aren't aren't secret and the amount you
pay is typically is typically small
because you you want to get lots of
people using you're using your your
parts basically so it doesn't make sense
to to to follow the sort of a biotech
model where you you know you patent
something and you charge the hell out of
it if you if anyone wants to to get
access to it so there's there's
definitely in some industries a trend
towards you know getting a very small
amount of reward for a lot of stuff
rather than overly protecting i have a
question about the community aspect of
your projects i'm probably not the only
one here who has managed a general
interest online community before and as
a longtime contributor and administrator
of wikipedia i know that a lot of work
goes into what you went might call the
behavior management aspect of an online
community and i was wondering you might
not have run into this yet depending on
how how much the projects have scaled
and what types of audience you're
getting but have you put any thought
into how you're going to manage some of
this community structure aspect of the
projects you need for bad behaviors not
necessarily bad behaviors but in terms
of instituting a culture within the
project of what types of collaborations
are expected what types of behaviors are
acceptable where the boundaries are do
you have administration within your
project well that's kind of interesting
it it i didn't talk about that enough
time but there are certain tools you can
apply now like there's the mechanical
turk at amazon where you know for
example i've used it to format the
columns in our one of our spreadsheets
so if the students forget the capital i
did not capitalize the molecules i can
just apply that Mechanical Turk it cost
me four cents and it's done and you can
do that repeatedly how many of you are
familiar with Mechanical Turk there's a
people yeah those are basically p
full of machines where you you send out
instructions and people reply to it and
they execute those those instructions
and we've coupled that with google
spreadsheets in a very nice way now you
can't do very sophisticated things with
it but what you're talking about which
is you know ensuring norms and formats
and things like that you can use things
like that if you know you don't have
enough people to manage but yeah I mean
the culture look when we have a Google
spreadsheet you know we let anyone edit
it but the email goes that as soon as it
gets edited so once in a while somebody
will come in they'll delete a cell
because they don't know what they're
doing and that's fine because we get an
email and we going to meet and we go
back to the previous version things so
what happens if people you know hundred
people do that a day then obviously
we'll have to change the way that we do
things and I've done that with my blog
you know going from having no controls
over who comments to putting a CAPTCHA
and finally admitting that I had to
moderate the comments because it was
just too much spam so you keep going on
and on until you you know you reached at
equilibrium the community on on plus
journals is always a question how much
commenting is going on there a lot or
not you're probably familiar that nature
tried experiment on that which lasted
six months and they shut it down and
said it didn't work and I looked at that
and so organized too early and it's too
short so when I was hired for plus and
so you know how you know can you get it
to the six years in six weeks as a no
give me five years I said oh ok I want
to somehow the stuff in the meantime so
sure so it is going to take a while it's
the plus one is now about two years old
last week is the first time I had to
delete a trawl comment they're starting
is getting there you and Ed just did a
big analysis of our commenting we're
doing better
and BMC journals it's happening but it's
going slowly and you know I'm trying to
keep my boss is happy by doing other
stuff and telling them give me five
years it takes time on the other hand
you know on my blog pretty much all I do
all day is debating drawl comments so
depends on on the topic they you know we
have some on purpose some not on purpose
difficulties on throwing things on +1
papers you need to go through
registration process which a lot of
people are grumbling about it's not easy
but it makes it really hard for trolls
and spammers to post stuff so is you
know you have to balance it you want to
deter those we don't want there and
still get people to post comments it's a
it's a fine line we're constantly
experimenting with kind of how much
difficulty it has to be for people to
how much ease for people to actually
participate and it goes you know which
paper how controversial the topic is how
interesting the topic is and I also
think of those things you know a plus
one paper is not a blog post when I
write a blog post on my blog expect all
the comments to happen within the first
24 to 48 hours and then that blog post
is dead pretty much when I think of +1
paper I think okay was published today
I'm interested in all the comments
they're going to accumulate on that
paper over the next 20 years so it's a
very different way of thinking and a lot
of people don't think that way but I
like to give like a historical thing can
you imagine if Paul Swan existed the boy
was is 60 70 years ago when Watson and
Crick published the structure of DNA can
you imagine if there are you know ways
to put notes and comments on that paper
and can you imagine 67 years later
reading all the notes and comments on
that paper well the text that's what you
do when you haven't using your students
come to your molecular biology lab
here's the history of your of your field
read the notes and comments in the
watson-crick pay
as a history of molecular biology
historians would love it molecular just
will love it and you see exactly how it
all works so I'm thinking of those in
long terms it's not a blog post it's
just the beginning of a much much longer
process one one thing that we did very
early on with open wet where was we we
decided that so anyone anyone can read
it it's readable by the world we wanted
it only be edited by people with with
accounts and we we set it up such that
if you want an account you need to use
your real name or what looks like your
real name and I'm having an a real email
address and some sort of affiliation and
if you're not affiliated and then you
know explain to us you know why we
should let you on and why you're
interested and we think that's helped a
lot because and you don't have your not
an anonymous person you you are who
you're who you're supposed to be when
you're when you're editing the wiki and
all your your edits can be can be
tracked so we think that that having
having it be real people and
attributable people editing the wiki
makes it makes a big difference and to
echo what Boris said over over four
years I think we've probably had to edit
about three things that were written on
the on the wiki that were inappropriate
for one or other reason so most babosa
depends a little bit on your reputation
if there are a single blogger or a very
small community the trolls are going to
be much bolder you know attacking PLoS
is not something that's taken lightly
it's a big institution and they you know
if you're a troll you probably assume
that you're going to be deleted and that
you're going to you know you are
attacking to stronger targets and you
know creations and those they're cowards
they're not going to post comments on
our papers they don't they don't do it
you know we also require the people log
in to edit but it's very totally
different reason is because my students
kept forgetting to log in so they
wouldn't get credit for the stuff they
hit so but yeah essentially it's as a
model makes a lot of sense it
things for you to read but to edit you
just have to register yeah the idea is
just like when you're publishing papers
you know you have your your publication
name that you always use so that you get
attribution for that and as a result you
want it to be good and we think it
should be the same when you're editing
stuff online hi I had a quick question
how or maybe do you think the practice
of open science will change in response
to recent legislative actions i'm
thinking of the increase in funding for
the NIH and NSF in the stimulus bill and
also the appointment of Obama's Science
Advisory Board I mean you know it was
his advisor is Harold Varmus who
unfortunately could not be here today
because he's traveling around the world
he is a busy person always been in here
is even more now so I'm hopeful I don't
know I have any no information on any
specifics I'm glad that some of the
money could saved for for science that
was initially deleted from the stimulus
package and then about half of it was
brought back so there's going to be some
money there's going to be some very
interesting forward-looking people
advising Obama Obama mentioned science
is like every week in his speeches so
I'm optimistic but I had absolutely no
individual pieces of information
anything I can say to directly answer
your question I mean a president who
uses a blackberry after one who didn't
use email I think it's got to make a
difference it's got to be better
I I'd like to thank boorish on Claude
and Barry for a really fascinating set
of presentations i think this video
would be interesting to look at in 5 10
years time to see how many of these
predictions have really come true and it
may be a really fascinating point in
time in the real expansion of open
science to have this conversation today
so very much appreciate all of you
coming please watch out for our next
announcements of other sessions and look
forward to seeing your other event thank
you so much thank you